Courtney Cox and her daughter Coco show
off their matching tattoos mom the
greatest thing in the world
and those new tats they got them with
Laura Dern and her two kids Ellery and
Jaya crazy amazing
the friend Star first shared this sweet
pick featuring all the kiddos and the
Oscar winner and it was in the next nap
that caught Coco Laura and Ellery
revealed their new ink which appears to
be a paper plane with the words go long
Courtney writes in the caption quote
adding a new layer to our 16-year
Christmas Eve tradition watch out we
might have sleeves by 2025. I just kind
of say what's happening in my life yes
probably not always served me well but
it's just who I am
court and Coco getting matching tattoos
should come as no surprise the two are
thick as thieves describe me as a child
in a single section it's absolutely
adorable curious
incredible sense of humor and quirky
you're annoying stop
I'm extremely thankful I'm I feel very
blessed to have Coco Coco whom Courtney
shares with ex David Arquette is also
just as talented as her mama but in the
singing Department she has a beautiful
voice yeah check out her incredible
singing voice as Mom plays the piano
[Music]
your sentences let me defenseless
[Music]
Coco's really she's into musical theater
and she's absolutely obsessed maybe more
than her schoolwork so yeah that's her
passion and um I would do anything to
continue to help support women in this
industry so she doesn't have any of the
same issues and she has all the
opportunities that she deserves Coco
just celebrated a big milestone she
turned 18 last June and now that she's
an adult she's preparing to leave home
for college soon so how does Courtney
feel about her only child moving away
she's gonna go as far away from La as
she can get but y'all see him so close
oh we're so close but she just can't
wait to go away and live on her own and
it's it's sad but don't worry Court's
not suffering from empty nester syndrome
just yet I I haven't even thought about
it and I think she's doing such a good
job at prepping for me for this she
never leaves a room she's never home I
mean and if she is literally door shut
and I don't know what she's doing back
there but I I don't think I'm going to
be as effective and now no matter the
distance the mother-daughter Duo have
tattoos to commemorate their tight Bond
[Music]